c-span ii
next encore book notes with betty bowell
lord
we talked with her in 1990 about her
book legacies a chinese mosaic
the collection of biographical stories
tell of life in china during the
cultural revolution and up until
tiananmen square
mrs lord left china at the age of eight
but returned in 1985 with her husband
then american ambassador to china
winston lord
as i write meaning as you're writing
your book i am nostalgic for china yes
what what made you want to say that in
the middle of this book
well because i start the book by saying
i'm ready to go home come back to
america
we had lived in china for three and a
half years
and while it was wonderful
i needed the space and
that only american can give in
in the sense that my schedule would be
my own
and that i
could
get away from all the
uh
so many things i had been hearing in
china and seeing but when you're up
close it's hard to to really put some
perspective on it so i was so ready to
go home
but as i was writing the book and
writing about my friends and writing
about china i became nostalgic so i
guess it proves that we're never
satisfied
many times i wish
that we could
be in two places at once
why the title uh legacies of chinese
mosaic
well legacies uh it refers to
the
cultural
the political
legacies
that the chinese people
carry on their shoulders every day
today
and then a chinese mosaic
refers to the stories that i tell about
the chinese people each one is a
separate story
and they put together as a mosaic i hope
we'll give the reader a picture of china
today
you often cite
in the book and your character's side in
the book uh the people you're writing
about the cultural revolution
would you try to
explain what the cultural revolution was
the cultural revolution
spanned the decade of 1966 to 1976.
it was a time
i think when mao
wanted to revitalize the revolution
i think he felt that somehow
the revolution had become bureaucratized
and he wanted to stir up the feelings of
people
for change again and he could do this
only by stirring up the young people
he told them that they were the true
revolutionaries not the party leaders
that ran the country
but
and so he unleashed
young people from teenagers to college
students
to go out do as they will and make
revolution
uh that they
only had to
read his little red book
follow him
and they could remake china into a
better china
well of course this caused tremendous
chaos
because
young people
uh spurred by the fury of
radical ideology are capable of all
things
and so many things
happen because
of their
their belief in mao and their belief
that they were
capable of remaking china into a better
country did you ever meet mao
i did not meet mao but of course my
husband winston
uh met mao about five times on five
separate trips to china he had seen him
he'd been traveling to china since the
early seventies since the secret trip he
made with dr kissinger what was mao's
i want to say claim to fame that's not
the right question what was he all about
i think he was a visionary i think
that
he was a man who wanted
to
rid china
of the foreigner
and he wanted to
put
china
on the map
i think he was quite successful in
getting people
to follow him and to
support his ideas
before
the 50s
but
i think this is always the problem with
uh people who stay in power too long
they they lose their
abilities to judge
and uh just as he stayed too long in
power
so has dong shopping because both men
as
leaders of their country
did many great things
but in the end they stay too
long did you approach writing this book
ah
i
i wanted to write on several levels
uh the i start each chapter with the
with just a headline about what happened
during the seven weeks
of china spring last year
and then
afterwards i would
if that is the sort of the frame of this
book if this is the mosaic we're talking
about that i would say would be the
frame
and then i would
go on and tell something about myself or
my family
and that perhaps would be the glue
and the mosaic pieces are the stories
of my friends
to give them a context to give them a
frame for the reader to read the stories
not just the stories
of individuals
but
of the chinese
people
during china spring when you open the
book
at the beginning yes and you come to
this page here and we're going to see if
we can get a close-up of this um
you see this symbol and you talk about
here that this symbol suggests that
there are other voices speaking yes you
don't realize it it kind of takes over
the book at some point and you see this
symbol a lot what is what's the purpose
of it well because i wrote
these stories as in the first person
because in many ways i feel that had i
never left china as a child
i could have been any one of those 20
people that i write about
so i write
as if i were
them
and therefore i use the i
well yeah here's the
page in the scholar and uh right in the
middle of the page
you see this symbol
and i want to ask you who was the
scholar
uh
i don't know who the scholar is
it's one of there are two chapters um
in this book where i'm not sure who they
are because they're people i've never
met
during the time that i was in china
i had asked many people
if i could interview them
and many of them
agreed
others who had heard from friends and
friends that i was doing so
would send me
tapes with their stories
and
the scholar
was after my farewell party
i'd gotten a whole
bunch of presents
from friends who'd come there and among
them were some tapes
and the scholar
apparently
there was no beginning there was no end
there was no name
there was nothing except a voice
speaking to me
for hours and hours and hours
and that's
one of the most moving stories i think
because
here's a man
that
lost
his
right to be a man
because of politics
how
when he was a young man he was sent to
help with the
land reform program
and while he was there he was
asked to
designate certain people in the village
as landlords
but there were no
people
in his particular district who are
actually landlords
so he said he thought the party could
not possibly mean
for him to name somebody who was not who
did not fit the category
so he did not
and then the orders at that time went
down that up that most people had to
name about five percent
of their district as landlords
and he could not name one and he didn't
as a result
he was named
as an enemy
of the people
and he was sent to
hard labor
while he was at hard labor
they had a a propaganda troupe a musical
and comedy kind of
propaganda
group
and
because he was a musician
he was asked to participate in in the
programs
but
they needed him to be a woman
and so they made him a woman not only
did they make
him play a woman on stage
but they wouldn't cut his hair
so his hair grew very very long
and they dressed him they only gave him
clothes of a woman to wear and he had no
choice
but to wear women's clothes
wear his hair long
and be
a woman for all extensive first
purposes
if you looked at him quickly you
couldn't tell
and he was forced to
take that role
for many many many years
and later
during the cultural revolution
when uh his wife was made to divorce him
he had a terrible setback a terrible
nervous breakdown and doing that nervous
breakdown
he
somehow reverted
to talking to his wife
as if she were there
and then one day
she he started to put on her clothes
and while he put on her clothes he went
out outdoors
and uh
went to the uh the uh public toilet
and
mistakenly of course went into the men's
toilet
at which point he was he was shoed out
and then there was no choice for him
except to go to the women's toilet
and when he went to the women's toilet
the women screamed of course
he didn't he didn't he was out of it by
that time he didn't really understand
what happened and as a result of that he
was put back in jail
for for sexual crimes so
this man
sent me the story but what is amazing
about this man
is that
he had written a book of poetry
that analyzed
the poetry of the ancients
and he eventually
regained his his position as a teacher
and he retired at the age of 70
as a teacher
how did he find you
i think he must have known a lot of our
mutual friends
who i had been interviewing
and it was very funny because i had not
interviewed anybody
with a point of view of
how the politics had affected
femininity
or
masculinity and it was toward the very
end when i was probing for this
particular problem
that
i would
tell my friends i'm looking for someone
who i could interview on this particular
subject about marriage
about being spinsters about divorce
and as you usually when when i asked my
friends to do this i would then get
back well we found someone for you or
let me introduce you to another friend
but
when i asked about this particular
problem i think it was quite late
in my stay
and it was my farewell party and i think
they they felt that i did not have time
to interview him and he just sent it
anonymously to me
he had 20 you have 20 people that you
write about and and you also we listen
to their voices through what they had to
say in your book how many
did you
decide i mean how many how many were in
front of you that and you had to whittle
it down to 20. oh
many many i think i have about
500 hours of tapes
what have you done with those tapes i i
plan to eventually give them to a
library of oral history
are they all in chinese yes
somebody will have to learn but i think
it'll be very valuable
for historians many many years from now
you were born in china yes shanghai
shanghai
are you
for all intents and purposes fluent in
chinese
how did you keep your language well i
didn't i had to relearn it i came here
when i was eight years old
at that time my parents thought we would
be going back to china and so frankly
from the moment i landed here they
started speaking to me in english they
put me in school the second day i was in
america
thinking that i
if i stayed a year or two here i would
go back fluent in english they spent so
much time teaching me english and
stuffing english into my head as a child
of eight
the other just popped out
and it wasn't until i was ready for
college almost the year before i went to
college that i realized that it was
being so stupid
that
all the time that my parents
spoke to me in chinese i always replied
out of habit in english that would that
i would have to
make
a try to read
to relearn chinese
and of course because i had heard it for
so many years
it was not hard
but learning to read and write was
harder
parents still alive yes yes yes why did
they come here in the first place
my father was assigned after the war
to come and buy equipment for china he
was an engineer he is an engineer
and where did you move to brooklyn
why brooklyn
well it was after the war in 1946
housing was really a problem my father
worked i think
near downtown new york
and
that was the place where he found a
place for us to live what do you most
remember about your
upbringing around the new york area yeah
in brooklyn
brooklyn dodgers
[Laughter]
well yes that's true
i felt that my americanization really
happened because i became a dodger fan
once i became a dodger fan and rooted
for jackie robinson all the kids
accepted me
was it difficult being chinese and
growing up in
white america
you're not going to believe this and
nobody else is going to believe it i
think all a lot of people are going to
write me letters
but
no i didn't
i didn't find i found
in ps number eight i learned to speak
english with a teacher named mrs
rappaport she was wonderful
infinite patience
exacting
as i said once i learned how to
speak english once i learned how to
play the american games
i didn't find it troublesome at all
and how many people in your family are
your sisters
my i have two sisters
and my father and mother are here and
you're right about both your sisters and
your books yes and how many people in
your family are back in china
all the rest how many is that ruffle oh
i don't know i've never counted but when
my parents came to to beijing the uh the
first time we had a family reunion of
people who are my relatives
just in beijing alone
of 60.
and that doesn't count the other towns
you grew up in brooklyn where did you go
to college i went to college at tufts
university and graduate school at the
fletcher school of law law and diplomacy
remember in reading the book the dates i
remember and correct me if i'm wrong it
was 1946 that you came here to the
united states
you first return in 73 that's right and
what was the purpose of that visit
i wanted to see china i wanted to see my
relatives
uh winston had gone had been making
several trips many trips
and i was anxious
to see
what had happened before you talk about
the trip back there where did you meet
winston lord at graduate school and that
was where
that was at fletcher school of law and
diplomacy and he believe it or not on a
dance floor the first thing he asked me
was the question that you had asked me
before
had i encountered racial prejudice
growing up in america and
what year did you meet him in 1959
when did you marry 1963.
and
what was it about the two of you that
growing up in a mixed family in this
country what made it easy for you
in other words why the marriage what why
the marriage well
we have a very odd odd
it's not your your your
run-of-the-mill or mixed marriages as a
matter of fact
both my parents
both my parents in-laws and my own
parents
if we ever had a fight winston i would
probably take the other side
so
we were both welcomed into each other's
family and i think that makes a big big
difference
when two people of different backgrounds
marry
after you mary where did you married
where did you live
washington
and what did uh winston was a foreign
service officer
where was he assigned
uh washington the whole time uh no
we were here for about three three or
four years and then we went overseas to
geneva
and in the opening of the book you've
list your other
literary achievements one of them is
fiction
spring moon when did you write that and
what was that
i wrote the novel spring moon in i
finished it in 1981 that's when it was
published it took me six years to write
it's a story it's a novel
about china from
really covering the time that china had
been trying to modernize really since
the late 19th century to the 70s
as told
as seen through the eyes
of a woman named spring moon
who starts out in life
with bound feet
and
not being able to leave the garden walls
of the
homestead
and
then takes part
in
the political turmoil of china
and then the second listing is a
non-fiction book called eighth moon what
was that eighth moon is actually my
first book i wrote that when my sister
sansan
left china
in 1961
and 1962
when she arrived in in america we had
been separated for 17 years
i had seen her last when she was about a
six-month-old baby
and met her at the airport and coming
down the runway was a 17 year old
girl that was my sister
i
started of course to catch up with all
those years
and i found myself fascinated by her
life
so different from my own
and yet
quite typical of
a young person growing up in china
during the revolutionary period
right after the
liberation of china by the communists
so
i wanted somebody to write the story
because in the 60s
people knew very little about china
and people usually
had opinions about china colored by
their politics whether they were
pro-taiwan or pro
mainland
but here was a story
of
a young girl
who saw the changes
without any political axe to grind
and told from a very simple story
of growing up
i tried to find somebody to write the
story
but i knew
of no writers who could speak chinese
so being 23 and quite foolish i didn't
know what it was to write a book and i
decided to quit my job and give it a try
what were you doing then i was working
with a fulbright exchange program
and how did the book do
it did quite well for first book it was
translated into about i think 18
languages
it was a reader's digest condensed book
but
i paid for this
ease in which i wrote
because i didn't write for
almost
10 12 years
i was scared to again
because
somehow i felt
that
people would find me out as an imposter
after i wrote eighth moon i started
going to the drugstore
picking up all those magazines on how to
break into publishing or how to become a
writer and how to write memoirs or
biographies and started reading they
scared me half to death i didn't do any
of the things that they had told me to
do
and so surely i felt that if i wrote
again
people would find me out as
not a writer at all not a genuine writer
so i was too scared to write and i
didn't write until until spring moon
where is sansan today sansa's working in
washington
you have another book to your credit for
children in the year of the boer and
jackie robinson yes when did you write
that and what was it i wrote that after
spring moon
it was um
a story that i had tried to tell
in an article for some magazine
but when i wrote it
from the adult point of view it didn't
seem to work
because
my life has been rather
free of conflict and
and
disappointments
so
the heart of a novel the heart of
anything an adult
writes about is conflict is struggle
and
somehow when i wrote it didn't work
but suddenly then i thought about
writing it from a child's point of view
which would not reflect upon the
credibility of the teller
and that's when i
wrote it
a fictionalized version of my first year
in america
and instead of
as betty balord betty bao
as shirley temple wong
one of the stories you tell in the book
i'd like to have you
share with us and that's the story that
when
you were going to become a diplomat's
wife yes
and and you had to you had to go through
a process with the state department with
what's called a gs-15
mr schultz i believe mr zlook
tell us about yes
well as you know when foreign service
officers marry any foreign national
the foreign national has to go through
a security check which is understandable
but in addition to that
they have to
meet with somebody
uh in the government
uh i guess to to see whether at that
whether the fiance would aptly represent
the united states of america
well in most times most people who go in
for such a test are asked who's the
president of the united states and
can you sing the first line of the
star-spangled banner and
that's about it
so i didn't take it very very seriously
i had grown up here i had gone to
college i had a master's degree i didn't
think there was any problem
so i went to see mrs look
and i don't understand to this day why
misters look gave me a two-hour
test
that
was harder than i think what winston
took or anybody else took to get into
the foreign service here i was just
going again as a wife
um the first question he asked me very
very seriously was who is vardis fisher
do you know no yeah did you have the
answer i didn't have the answer and
nobody i've asked since then has been
able to tell me who bartus fisher is
well and here you are running a book
program you mean to tell me you don't
know who vardas fisher is yes i did who
is he he is a writer
of the oregon trail
you see
you know you have been enlightened
and then i was asked to uh give this
my husband said that i should have been
able to answer this one uh the starting
lineup of the green bay packers
and there were a lot of other strange
questions yes yes why
why does it matter who a diplomat for
the united states
why does it matter who his or her spouse
is
well
i think the rules have changed quite a
bit since
since the early 60s but i think it was
left over from the war
when when when people were
i can only assume that they were
marrying uh
a lot of foreigners
who
then had to assume responsibilities and
duties as the wife of a diplomat
but
in the 70s
you no longer have to
to make
your wife a partner in your career
before the 1972 directive in the state
department
women and wives or spouses of that time
let's face it women
foreign service officers were graded
in the officer's
efficiency report
they were not paid
they they were not even employed
but this was part of the old
uh
system
did you work all through the period
there besides writing your books that uh
say from your husband went to china in
71 and you went in 73. what did you do
from 73 to now or 73 to the time you
went tours i used to be a dancer i used
to dance with the washington uh
dancers in repertory here in washington
i taught dance
i also uh
worked with the associated council of
the arts
and
and wrote
were you assigned to any other foreign
post besides geneva no before you went
to because winston left the foreign
service after five years so after the
geneva post he left the foreign service
although he continued on working in the
area of foreign policy i remember
another day i think that you went back
to china in 79
yes what was that trip for
uh to see family again
i went in 75 when i could not see family
it was a
pretty tense period in in
bilateral relations at that time
so i went in
with winston on an official trip
and i had hoped to spin off from them
but
the atmosphere was quite chilly so i
didn't stay
and then i went back and not 79. did
people know when they saw you in china
that you were not
that it's hard to know the american
citizens they know you were not living i
mean could they tell right away well i
don't think they can tell now because
people have changed their way of dress
but in 1971 when i first went there were
very very few tourists at all in china
and
even though i tried to dress as closely
as possible to the people in the street
nevertheless they could tell by my shoes
or
by the fact that i wore a wedding band
that
i didn't come from
that i was not a native chinese anymore
and it was very odd going through the
streets hundreds of people would follow
me everywhere
why
because i looked different i may not
look different to you but i look
different to them
i was in curiosity
page 120
the journalist was is it titled the
chapter chinese go through life wearing
masks yes
the ones that tradition decrees
the ones that society decrees and since
liberation the ones that the party
decrees yes
did did you have a mask
yes i i uh
i tried not to have a mass because
uh
i wanted to get be
to be friends to get close to people but
there are certain times when you do have
to to put on a mask especially as a
diplomat's wife
um
you have to pretend you're angry when
you're
when
when you're not you have to pretend
you're happy when you're not you have a
lot of things you have to do do
americans have masks
not as much americans i have been taught
to shoot from the hip
to tell it the way it is
um
to to be
much more straightforward
because they represent only themselves
americans are raised as individuals
chinese have responsibilities to the
family to the clan to the country and
it's a different way of thinking so that
if you make a fool of yourself
i'm not likely to blame your son or your
father
i would just think oh
you made a fool of yourself
but chinese usually link it all together
and so you have you have
you have additional burdens to be good
is there any way to describe what life
is like for
the average chinese of the 1.2 billion
or whatever the number is well there's
no i can tell you what it's like in the
cities
usually
they have
a living space
in beijing at least in the big cities of
less than the size an individual has a
living space less than the size of a
double bed
it's very very space is very very
confined
and still there are a lot of housing
problems for them
so living in a tight space also
calls upon
putting on masks
and there are many times when two or
three generations have to share an
apartment
and then again
you have to pretend
that
you like your mother-in-law very very
much because if you didn't you couldn't
live together
so that that's where the masks come in
and the government usually assigns you
to your work and your schooling
during the decade of reforms there'd
been other outlets
but more and more
it involved using the back door using
connections
and the system had become more and more
corrupt
so that
knowing someone who can pull strings
was a great help in life because
otherwise you couldn't get things done
in fact i
once had to
indulge in corruption
it involved getting a
car phone for winston
um we were told
that
for the ambassador's car to have a car
phone
it would take three and a half years
so
then i was told that if i could get
somehow two tickets for an allen de leon
concert for this chinese
who
gave out these car phones for the
government
that somehow miraculously winston would
then have a car phone
so i went around
and
got two car two tickets for an allen de
leon
concert at the workers stadium for this
woman and sure enough the next day we
got the car phone
i
felt i felt very guilty about it because
this is the kind of small corruptions
that leads to big corruptions
but on the other hand winston was in the
car going to the airport or elsewhere
at least one or two hours a day
which meant that he was out of touch
with the with the office and i
i guess i rationalized that it was
important
you say that you're i remember reading
that your husband
was proud to say that he'd been to all
23 districts in china uh provinces
provinces
but you
were glad that you didn't have to make
every one of those trips yes yes
i love to sit
and talk to people
i'm not a great
tourist
i prefer getting to know the people
and usually when i am with winston and
touring
we usually don't get
to to really know people we get to to go
to banquets and talk on official
subjects
and
i usually have to do a lot of the
translation at least
and and i find that it's less landscapes
are less interesting to me than people
and he could speak what you say pigeon
mandarin
yes
well this is because when
he started out as a foreign service
officer because he had married a chinese
national the state department told him
that he would never have anything to do
he could he would be barred from
participating in china policy
because of his marriage to a chinese
that rule of course was changed later
but at the time when he was
learning languages
he thought why learn chinese if i could
never use it professionally
when i read a little bit
say unlike the peripatetic winston
what did you mean by peripatetic winston
he loves to travel
i was raised in a family in which having
a wonderful holiday meant sitting at the
kitchen table drinking tea
nibbling watermelon seeds and talking
father mother and i would often linger
there from breakfast until long after
the witching hour yes yes
talking talking talking
my father and mother are great
storytellers
and so i was
the pleasures for me have always been
conversation
and
because we had no other family but each
other
here in the states
i often sit and they would tell me about
my grandparents
uh
my other relatives in china
and
i'm very lucky that they did otherwise i
don't think i could write about china
with the
with the facility that i can
without those stories without somehow
feeling that i had lived them too
americans are self-selected breed
programmed by their genes to be forever
on the go and cursed by the fates
never to enjoy luxuriating in the
material comforts and spiritual
splendors of home
now you have to say that that's an
i was i was trying making fun of both
sides and that's the way i make fun of
americans
um
the opposite you know americans i think
in many ways are a
self-selected breed we're a country of
immigrants
if we didn't want to move
and if we didn't want to seek
push back the horizons
we would not come to america
from all over the world those of us who
have come
most of us it's not a easy trip i don't
mean
in terms of transportation i mean
leaving one culture
going to another starting over
these are difficult things i mean and
then
what amazes me most about the american
spirit is the spirit that
had people go
and settle the west where people lived
hundreds and miles away from each other
for people who like to sit at the
kitchen table
it's it's difficult
you also talk about language you see
after a while the american side
slumbered however unable to appreciate
how the mere act of speaking in chinese
confers so much satisfaction that what
is said hardly matters what about
language is it which one is harder
chinese or english
chinese perhaps is easier to speak
except for the fact of tones maybe not
take it back let's say english i think
english is easier easier easier a
language there's such a dramatic
difference there's such a dramatic
difference
uh chinese is easier grammatically
because you can toss words up together
and they somehow fall fall together
there's there's
less grammar
there's less grammar but then there's
the problem of tones which the same
sound with the four different tones can
mean totally something else as i read
the book i saw you jumping back and
forth chinese american chinese american
language
customs
masks where are you now in your own head
it depends on the occasion
i think now when i'm with chinese
after living there three and a half
years
i feel very much at home with them but
of course when i'm here in america i
also feel very much at home here i think
it's it's a choice now for me
the two parts
have never been at war with one another
so
i think i'm doubly blessed
this is the book legacies a chinese a
chinese mosaic betty balor is our guest
and we're talking about a book she
completed in what month
last year uh in
the end of october
how much of your experience
during the tiananmen square happenings
did you want to write about in this book
i actually did not go into the square
except one evening
uh
although i was not
any longer the ambassador's wife
winston had left the country
i had been hired by cbs to be a
consultant actually on the gorbachev
visit
in january
and i had returned to china to work for
them
but
i was re i am recognizable in china so i
did not want to become a part of the
story
thinking that if i went into the square
and was recognized
that i would become part of the story
so i only went once at night and another
time when we were doing 48 hours with
dan rather when i was standing on a
truck so i wasn't part of the crowd
most of
legacies is not about my participation
except
that what i saw
i saw
people who were suddenly
together as a community i'd been in
china for three and a half years
and it was
becoming less
and less a community
and people were out of sorts all the
time
because of the frustrations of life and
yet during those seven weeks
when the students
marched for a fairer society and against
corruption
everybody was nice to each other in a
way that was just wonderful perhaps it's
like
new york after a blackout
perhaps it's like san francisco
after an earthquake
suddenly
neighbors became friends
and people were helping each other and
so i was very privileged to be there and
to see that
i
would guess that you and your husband
and friends sit around and talk about
where china is going and where it will
be yes what's your best guess ten years
from now
i think china will always have a
difficult time uh
uh
with
solving the problems of a billion people
it's poor
uh it's education has been neglected but
i do feel that sometime soon
there will be a much more open
and much more progressive government in
china how soon
within the next two to five years and
why do you
why do you predict that
because the people who have
who ordered the soldiers to shoot at the
students
destroyed their own myth
that they had worked so hard to create
which was
really the one of the founding pillars
of the communist party
that the people's army would not shoot
at its own people
because the warlord armies did and
because they said that wilmington armies
did
and other people did but not the
the
people's army
but this time
everybody saw that they had done so
and really for
for no reason
the the the problem could have been
solved by attrition very easily when i
left china
two or three days before june 3rd and
4th the weekend of the massacre
there were hardly any people left in the
square
people were leaving and if they had
waited another week i think the crisis
would have been over
even if the government felt that they
had to clear the square by
by a show of force they could have done
it
in other ways than tanks and bullets
in 1976
when the despicable gang of four who
everybody in the world knows about that
their the horrors they have committed in
which every chinese
would despise
even they
when clearing
tenement square in 1976
when citizens went into the square to
object to them
they did it by spraying water
not bullets
are you going to go back
i will go back when
there's a different china than there is
today when it's not so oppressive
when i can feel that i can meet my
friends and not get them into trouble
when i can feel that
if somebody takes my picture there it's
not going to be used for propaganda
purposes
is that a special problem for you
because you're chinese originally from
china or would you say that to all
americans if they ought to stay out of
china no i think it's my
my
i think businessmen who have businesses
there
should conduct business
i think
i think if you're a tourist it would
depend on whether you have other chances
to go to china in the future
no this is only a decision for myself
one of the things that seemed unusual
when i read your book was that
i guess i just didn't expect it at one
point you said i'm right sitting here
writing in jackson hole
wyoming yes why did you pick that well i
felt that
i needed the peace and quiet uh of the
mountains
um
i didn't i had just
i didn't want to go through the getting
settled back into the apartment at the
same time as writing a book that i
wanted to
to write very much and as quickly as i
could
so going into the mountains was a great
help it did work then it worked
with the 500 you say hours of tape
you've got yeah all in chinese yes did
you translate it all
no what i uh what i did was i had some
help in the transcribing but as you know
tapes
sometimes i would have
12 hours of tapes for which
i would use only a little bit of it
some of the chapters are
quite small i think none of the stories
go on beyond 15 pages
so
but the
the transcription that was done from the
tapes was done with by by a group of
people other than myself is there
another book
that you want to bring out of these all
these tapes you've got
um
i think
my next book will be a novel like spring
moon
i started a novel before i went to to
beijing as ambassador's wife
um
and i still have to finish that one so
that one will come next
which one of the 20
did do you or if that's maybe not your
favorite which one of the 20 um means
the most to you the characters you write
about
oh it's so hard to select but i suppose
there are only two women
among the 20
and i suppose
i would pick the woman that the story of
the actress
because
it is so
heartbreaking
and yet
i feel that
she has
survived
her trials
magnificently she is today a wonderful
actress
and someone who brings many hours of
pleasure to the chinese people so even
though
she
went through
hell personal hell because at the age of
seven
she didn't know better
than to do
that the government could be wrong
because when the government told her
that her father was an enemy she
believed it
were you able to name any of your
characters i mean i notice and say the
stories i tell are true because they are
i had no choice but disguise the people
who live them is that everybody yes in
the book yes yes
would the child
from what you know the chinese
government will they take your book
and go over it with a fine fine-tooth
comb and try to locate some of these
folks no these stories are not
these stories are the stories that were
told to me personally so that they have
depth and feeling
but these stories are very common
because
the communists
do not
look at you as a person they look at you
as an intellectual a worker
or a farmer
they put you in categories
and the fate of people within that
category are pretty much the same
so even though individually they reacted
to their
to the various political campaigns
differently
um nevertheless
their stories are quite
typical they're not unusual so i would
think it would be quite hard to pin down
who exactly
i'm writing about
what kind of a grade would you give
forget the politics of china and if you
found yourself having to run 1.2 billion
people
what kind of a grade would you give the
administrative function in china right
now of keeping track of all those people
and collecting taxes and
and paying them and
i i think that i think that the
organization the network is very very
deep and thick
there are many many places bureaucracy
is incredible it's not just the
communists
china invented bureaucracy
but what has happened is
the system is very comprehensive
but what has happened is every point of
this comprehensive system
the person has
become corrupt
in the sense of the tax collector
will collect taxes from you but not from
a friend
the tax collector will
will trade uh how much tax you have to
pay
for
a favorite in return
so i would
i would say the system is not working
and that is why the people marched
and this is kind of jump this is
may not fit together but i think you're
giving
what i'm getting at it is also true that
at every step along the way somebody
always darted out and squeezed them the
neighbor down the road who now charged
for the use of that road the village
hedman who withheld fertilizer for
favors the local party secretary who
fixed the quota of grain they must sell
it artificially low prices to the state
now peasants joke that at least when the
landlord used to whip them three times a
day
they could withstand the prescribed
ordeal because they could count on what
was to follow
is that all that kind of
treatment of your fellow
person is at all a factor of this system
that's over there or is it the chinese
people
no i think it's it's been it's it's um
it's when people are frustrated
when you and i
can't get things done
uh
you
perhaps if our money were uh if we could
not walk in the front door of a store
to get what we wanted to do
eventually if we needed what was in that
store
uh badly enough
you and i would find out who works in
that store
and then
is there somebody we know
who knows these people and can i
give them
a call and get them to take me to the
store so that i can get the thing that i
need
it's not
something so terrible that's
incomprehensible it's because
people
because the party makes so many
decisions
for the people that they can't seem to
manage
to
to to
manage
their
their destiny
so more and more
people find other ways underhanded ways
under the tableways
connection
making connections to resolve these
problems
another line is
if the united states with its legacy of
an open society and a free press could
be reshaped by the small screen imagine
its impact on china you're talking about
television yes what kind of control i
mean what kind of television do the
people of china have today uh i think
there are almost 200 million sets there
and uh people in the cities have them
and at least villages would have one in
which everybody sort of come around and
take a look at so the net again the syst
the dissemination through television is
is very good it's very good
uh they have one channel
no they have uh three channels three
channels but they they do not put only
chinese programs on their channels
because they can't afford to
they have many programs that they have
bought from the united states for
instance hunter is a regular program in
china
so is mickey mouse and donald duck and
walt disney
other
pictures so they they bought i think
from cbs over 200 old movies
which are shown
and a little house on the prairie was
the biggest hit in china too what impact
did that have on the society tremendous
impact tremendous impact
because
that particular program is about
an american family who sticks together
who have differences
who have generational problems and yet
they have somehow
worked it out
amicably
and it was a great surprise to the
chinese who had been taught through
propaganda for years and years and years
that americans don't care about family
this is what the book looks like it's in
your bookstores and it's on the best
seller list legacies the chinese mosaic
by betty balord our guest for the past
hour thank you for joining us thank you
about a year after our 1990 interview
with betty bell lord fawcett books
published this paperback version of her
book legacies
fawcett is division of random house at
201 east 50th street new york new york
10022
ms lord has written other books
including spring moon 8th moon and the
children's book in the year of the boer
and jackie robinson